as far as baseball movies go major
league was definitely a Grand Slam the
1989 comedy featured a sweetheart season
for a down-and-out Cleveland Indians
filled with lovably bonkers characters
friction between players and team
executives and a lot of feel-good fun
that still resonates with audiences
decades after the fact two sequels
followed the original and a third has
been knockin around the ballpark for
ages let's take a look back at the
untold truth of major-league
winner-takes-all
writer director David Ward originally
came up with his concept for major
league based on his own personal love
for the ballclub it featured the
Cleveland Indians who again lost out on
a chance at the World Series title in
2016 hadn't taken home a trophy since
1948
so Ward a longtime fan wanted to turn
their luck around even if it was just on
screen as he told Yahoo Sports I started
to feel like the only way I would see
the Indians win anything is if I made a
movie where they did I realized it would
have to be a comedy because nobody would
take this seriously away game although
the b-roll shots of Cleveland Municipal
Stadium were filmed in the Rock and Roll
capital of the world
most of the movie was made in another
Midwestern City Milwaukee yes although
it might seem like a bit of sports
sacrilege for a movie about one ball
team to be shot on another's turf much
of major league was filmed at Milwaukee
County Stadium which was home to the
Brewers Ward told ESPN that the reason
for the shooting locale shift was that
the cleveland browns the town's NFL team
was using the stadium at the time for
their preseason games so it was unfit
for filming talk about a foul ball
performance enhancement given his
torpedo-like public profile in recent
years it might not seem too out of
character now for Charlie Sheen to have
used performance-enhancing drugs to beef
up for his part in this movie of course
what a drug Charlie Sheen what might be
surprising though is why she told Sports
Illustrated that he considers the sport
of baseball not just a hobby but a
religion and that it's the only sport he
cares about watching his favorite team
was actually the Indians rival the
Cincinnati Reds meanwhile he even played
baseball in high school and was
teetering on making it to the big time
at one point taking steroids Sheen
reveals made his fastball reach up to 85
miles per hour but
also made him a little testy when it
came to criticism of Rikki Vaughn's
signature hairdo the actor admitted that
because he was so on edge from the drugs
he got into some scuffles with bar
patrons who made fun of his raised mane
during off time from the shoot years
later people still consistently call him
Wild Thing though maybe for different
reasons these days and he even revived
the character for Game seven of the 2016
World Series matchup between the Indians
and the Chicago Cubs in hopes of
bringing a little luck on his on-screen
team dream team while a lot of the
actors had to attend baseball camp to
prepare for their turns around the
diamond some of the cast members came to
the field with their own set of skills
already groomed Dennis Haysbert for
example was such a good hitter that he
actually did knock it out of the park
with those insane homers we saw on the
big screen and he didn't need Joe boo to
do it either Wesley Snipes on the other
hand was exactly the opposite of his
fast running screen ego Willie Mays
Hayes he said to have been terrible at
throwing and couldn't nearly run as
quickly as his base-stealing counterpart
double switch in major league the
central villainous was rachel phelps the
Blyth team owner who purposefully
assembled the ragtag ensemble in hopes
of having them fail so she could move
the organization to another site in the
end the joke was on her once the team
came together to win their division and
secure their standing in Cleveland by
selling out seats at their hometown
stadium however there was an alternate
ending in an earlier version of the
movie that got booed out of the theaters
originally Rachel was supposed to have a
scene that showed her as the not evil
mastermind behind their runaway success
who only acted mean to encourage the
budget squad to exceed all expectations
of them test audiences who saw the
original cut however didn't like the
turnabout and said that they wanted her
to stay bad because they've gotten so
used to hating her by the end free
agents long before he'd become a
household name for playing anxiety
addled agent Ari Gold in HBO's entourage
Jeremy Piven was chopped completely out
of major league Piven was originally
expected to appear as an insult hurling
benchwarmer for the team but his scenes
were left on the cutting room floor we
can certainly imagine what that would be
like Jesus Christ you all suck but have
a five-year lease on this place I'd shut
it down and work out of my
cardboard box by myself DoublePlay
although David Ward did return to helm
the 1994 follow-up film major league -
he doesn't exactly consider the film to
rank among his finest achievements he
publicly panned the second pick for
which he didn't write the screenplay as
being not as good as the first one and
said that it tried too hard to be funny
neither Ward nor Charlie Sheen were
involved with the third installment back
to the minors they both hated the movie
so much that neither of them even
counted as a major league movie and
widely refer to the sequel they're
hoping will happen next as major league
3 the closer Ward has written another
installment to the major league movie
birds that said to be set 20 years after
the original events after wild thing has
already retired from the sport the
character would be brought back to train
a new generation phenom pitcher who just
so happens to be his secret son Sheen
has said that he's fully on board with
the proposed project that the script is
definitely winning and that it has only
been delayed on account of Studio rain
for now thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]